quería preguntarle si son nuevas estas
acusaciones de mancuso y Qué representan
para la búsqueda de la verdad sobre el
conflicto en Colombia
sí buena noche no la mayor parte de las
declaraciones de mancuso ya eran asuntos
conocidos en los procesos de justicia y
paz en los procesos con los
paramilitares habían noticias sobre la
convivencia entre políticos mandos
militares
narcotraficantes paramilitares para una
labor de aniquilamiento de poblaciones y
también de enfrentamiento a la guerrilla
pero pues mancuso ha revelado cosas
gravísimas que de todas maneras
requieren una investigación profunda por
parte de la jurisdicción especial para
la paz Bueno más curso Busca ahora
entrar dentro de la justicia
restaurativa de la jep podría explicar
qué es esta justicia y qué implicaría
que mancuso entra se en ella
esa justicia de transición se creó en el
acuerdo de paz con la faz de la Habana y
supone que personas vinculadas a las
FARC o militares que se acojan a esa
justicia pueden participar en ella se
está considerando un caso especial de
mancoso en tanto mancuoso pretende
demostrar que él era un enlace entre el
ejército y los paramilitares para
combatir a la guerrilla y para
diferentes prácticas criminales Entonces
si la jurisdicción especial para la paz
valora que es pertinente y que además
está contribuyendo a la verdad que tiene
elementos nuevos que pueden ayudar al
esclarecimiento y a la reparación de las
víctimas Entonces lo aceptará para
iniciar ya las investigaciones donde se
tiene que demostrar la veracidad de cada
una de sus afirmaciones pero de todas
maneras lo que ya
genera muchísima perturbación y
inquietud en la sociedad colombiana
porque se está
confirmando de que en Colombia tuvimos
décadas en las cuales se realizó una
operación criminal conjunta entre
diferentes aparatos de poder entre ellos
el aparato gubernamental el aparato
militar el aparato paramilitar y los
narcotraficantes coaligados con
políticos para exterminar personas y
producir masacres y desplazamiento en
hora Colombia que ha atravesado de los
peores horrores que se puedan conocer en
el mundo quería preguntarle ahora
precisamente por las pruebas de las que
usted me hablaba incluso tiene 30 días
Para aportar estas pruebas sobre sus
acusaciones si la refrenda que
implicaciones podrían tener para los
nombres que aparecen en ellas
Pues por supuesto aportado documentos
suficientemente
probatorios pues se abrirían procesos de
investigación se tendría que vincular
procesos de investigación y acusaciones
a los responsables
y ahí habría que establecer Cuáles
procesos Van por las jurisdicción
especial para la paz y cuáles son
remitidos A la fiscalía general de la
nación y a los procesos de justicia
ordinaria